Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's mal einen Trend, der durch TikTok und Instagram läuft ohne Ende,
wir machen nämlich das Cinnamon Bread von Domino's!
Ich hab letztens erst davon erfahren. Ich war bei meiner Freundin Sarah,
die hat auch einen Instagram Sale Account.
Also Sale, Beauty... alles mögliche postet sie da, schreib ich euch mal in die Infobox!
Und sie hat gesagt: "Mach das unbedingt nach, das schmeckt soo lecker!"
Und am gleichen Abend war ich bei meiner Familie und da sagt mir meine Schwester
(Grüße gehen raus an Dilara!), die sagt: "Kiki, richtig lecker, probier mal!"
weil sie sich das gerade geholt hatte nach der Schule.
Und dann hat sie das gegessen vor mir und das sah so lecker aus,
mein Mund war schon so am sabbern und dann hab ich probiert
und das war eecht lecker!
(H: Ich hab's noch nicht gegessen!)
Du hast es noch nicht probiert, du warst ja nicht dabei!
(H: Du Gierige, hast mir nichts mitgebracht!)
Jaa! Wir haben alles alleine aufgefuttert! Das war so ein mega fluffiger Hefeteig
mit Zimt-Zucker und dann isst man das mit so 'nem Frosting, das mega
(H: Kann ich mir vorstellen!)
Ja, das Frosting war aber mega süß, mal gucken,
ob ich das vielleicht umwandle.
Aber jetzt zeig ich euch erstmal, wie ihr das easy peasy Zuhause alleine machen könnt.
Und zwar hab ich hier ganz normales Mehl, das ist Typ 405, das was ihr so kennt, Weizenmehl.
Und da geb ich jetzt Trockenhefe rein, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
stehen wie immer hier unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Einmal Trockenhefe rein, das Ganze verrühre ich jetzt,
da geb ich dann noch ein bisschen Puderzucker dazu.
Und eine Prise Salz, die Prise Salz hebt nochmal den süßen Geschmack.
Und anschließend bilden wir eine Mulde, geben da geschmolzene Butter rein,
lauwarme Milch und ein Ei. Und dann wird das mit den sauberen Händen verknetet.
So, den Hefeteig hab ich jetzt noch 3min auf der sauberen Arbeitsfläche geknetet
und dann merkt ihr auch schon, wenn er soweit ist.
Wichtig ist: Beherzigt meinen Tipp und gebt immer nach und nach das Mehl dazu.
Weil je nachdem, wie groß das Ei ist - es gibt ja Eiergröße S, M oder L,
ich hab jetzt Größe M verwendet - braucht ihr eben mehr oder weniger Mehl.
Und jetzt einfach zu einer Kugel rollen. Das macht ihr am besten indem ihr
hier einmal die Enden immer in die Mitte drückt.
Einmal umdrehen und so ein paar Mal auf der Arbeitsfläche im Kreis drehen.
Und jetzt schnappt ihr euch euer Backblech, wir lassen das jetzt nicht in der Schüssel gehen
sondern direkt das Backblech schnappen, ein Backpapier oben drauf
und dann den Hefeteig da drauf legen.
Und so lassen wir das Ganze zugedeckt ruhen, 30-45min.
Ich hab jetzt Zeit, ich lass es 45min gehen.
Wenn ihr keine Zeit habt, dann reichen auch 30min.
Achso und wir fahren jetzt Hamza, ne? In der Zeit?
(H: Ja!)
Ok, los geht's!
(H: Du fährst, besser gesagt!)
Ich fahr!
So, jetzt bin ich wieder Zuhause und so sieht jetzt das Original aus.
Sehr klein ist mir aufgefallen! Ich hatte das viel größer in Erinnerung.
Auf jeden Fall ist da eine ordentliche Portion Zimt-Zucker drauf, das machen wir jetzt auch.
Unser Teig ist jetzt schön aufgegangen.
Und wenn ihr das genauso groß haben möchtet, bzw. so "klein" wie bei Domino's,
dann nehmt einfach die Hälfte des Rezepts,
da ändert sich dann auch an der Backzeit nichts. Apropos Backzeit,
Ofen hab ich auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze jetzt vorgeheizt.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass der Ofen vorgeheizt ist.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch die Hände und drückt den Teig einfach runter,
und drückt ihn quasi in Form.
So, als nächstes verstreichen wir geschmolzene Butter auf dem Brot
und das hilft erstens beim Geschmack, Butter ist ja Geschmacksträger.
Zweitens für's Aussehen, das kriegt eine schöne Bräune
und drittens haftet jetzt unser Zimt-Zucker besser dran.
Und für Zimt-Zucker nehmt ihr euch wie der Name schon sagt ganz einfach
Zucker, rührt da ein bisschen Zimt ein
und jetzt verteile ich das auf der geschmolzenen Butter.
So, jetzt wird das Cinnamon Bread noch unterteilt und zwar in 8 Streifen.
Das heißt einmal in der Mitte durchschneiden
und dann links und rechts jeweils 2 Mal durchschneiden
und dann haben wir 8. Ihr könnt auch 10 oder 12 machen, ist auch nicht so schlimm.
So und jetzt wandert's in den Backofen, wie gesagt ganz wichtig:
vorgeheizt, 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze bis es richtig schön goldbraun ist.
Und wir kümmern uns in der Zwischenzeit um das Frosting.
So, hier drin befindet sich das Frosting bzw. das Icing, das kriegt man immer mit dazu
und ich hab schon probiert, es schmeckt echt mega süß!
Ist ne mega süße Masse! Und in den Zutaten steht da ist ein bisschen Zitronensäure drin,
und ein bisschen Vanillearoma.
Vanillearoma wisst ihr ja, schmeckt immer mega künstlich,
schmeckt überhaupt nicht gut. Daher nehm ich natürlich Vanilleextrakt.
Ihr könntet alternativ auch eine Vanilleschote nehmen, also das Mark.
Und was ich nehme ist eine Basis auch Doppelrahmfrischkäse und Puderzucker.
Und das verrühre ich jetzt erstmal, geb da schon direkt so einen Spritzer
Zitronensaft rein und verdünne das mit Milch.
Und anschließend kommt dann das Vanilleextrakt dazu.
So, das ist mein fertiges Icing.
Natürlich ist es nicht schneeweiß wie das Original von Domino's
weil ich hab jetzt hier keine Konservierungsstoffe, keine Verdickungsmittel.
Ich hab hier natürlich echte Vanille drin und das macht sich dann auch im Geschmack bemerkbar.
Hier nochmal zum Vergleich:
Also das ist natürlich nicht sehr natürlich!
Und deswegen gehe ich jetzt auch davon aus, dass das, was ich jetzt hier zubereitet habe,
natürlich besser schmeckt. Das klingt immer so arrogant, ne?
Ich will das so gar nicht sagen.
(H: Aber du hast richtiges Vanilleextrakt benutzt, deswegen.)
Ja das sind halt die Zutaten, die den Unterschied machen, ne?
(H: Natürlich, ja!)
Aber ich bin trotzdem gespannt, wie jetzt gleich das Brot schmeckt.
Das ist nämlich auch in ein paar Minuten fertig.
Okay, Hamza und ich haben hier grad schon Party gemacht weil das soo lecker schmeckt!
Wir feiern das einfach so! Vor allem ging's sehr schnell, ne?
Man braucht auch wenig Zutaten, wir hatten jetzt alles da, also nichts wildes.
Und das Gute ist - komm ruhig näher ran -
das ist mega softer Teig, zum Glück nicht zu dick ausgerollt,
sonst würd's sehr schwer im Magen liegen.
Und die Kruste hier oben ist total kross! Also hier oben sehr knusprig
und hier total weich.
Und dann müsst ihr das in das Icing dippen, ich demonstrier das mal.
Einmal so richtig schön reindippen und dann einfach genießen. Lecker!
Also das hier, das Cinnamon Bread mit dem Icing und dann einfach noch 'ne geile Netflix Serie
und euer Abend ist perfekt!
Also macht's unbedingt nach, schreibt mir wie's euch gefallen hat
und ganz, ganz wichtig: schreibt mir in die Kommentare welches Rezept ich
als nächstes nachmachen soll.
Kennt ihr vielleicht noch irgendein Original aus irgendeinem Laden/Lokal,
das ich unbedingt mal nachmachen soll?
Dann schreibt's mir rein und dann kümmer ich mich drum!
(H: Und das ist unbezahlt!)
Und das ist unbezahlte Werbung, keine Kooperation!
Ansonsten ja, lasst uns einfach in den Kommentaren schreiben, abonniert meinen Kanal,
das ist auch komplett kostenlos, dann verpasst ihr auch solche genialen Rezepte nicht mehr.
Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezeptvideo oder bei meinem nächsten Vlog!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!